and my sisters as usual all the times
when I come speak it's gonna every
Sunday I'll give you a great hiding
alhamdulillah on Sunday on a Sunday
Friday seven people became Muslim and
the night before one person from where
from music or church no Nigeria no it's
tornado
Muslim eight people become Muslim but
you check the videos on our Instagram
and Tick Tock that's that alhamdulillah
so alhamdulillah Islam
Islam alhamdulillah why because Islam
because allowed our sound reasoning and
our natural destination Christianity is
dying go ahead
thank you very much and as you know it's
nothing to do about down here I want you
to if you can comment on what happened
in a shop in Peckham last week I don't
know about it
relations to a young lady went into the
shop yeah yeah to get a refund okay
why
that's what we're trying to establish
but you know you don't have no clue
but you know what happened is actually
if you kept Enlighten us you know what
happened
they come it's my area
yeah what happened she went into a wig
shop yeah to get a refund
let me explain okay so she wanted a
refund he refused okay then she said
she's gonna fight the money
Goods up yeah then she attempted to
leave the shot yeah he didn't got hold
of her and tried to strangle her that's
wrong
and what occurred was video filmed as a
direct result of that yeah the shot has
now shut down and people in Patton are
refusing to use that shot yeah because
he sorry let me say people have refused
here if that shop reopens they're gonna
buy cop every single Indian owned shop
in Peckham what about that Injustice
because the other India has nothing to
do with it you have to be just for
example not if an Arab man or press a
black lady or Asian woman we cannot go
and oppress every Arab man because Islam
teach us a bit of Islam Allah said
whether I tell you the words
people should not be taking vote
accountable for other people's sins you
understand so we have vertical and good
people in every nation I understand so
we cannot boycott every Indian shop
because there's an Indian guy who
mistreated you understand yeah I don't
agree with that likewise not agree with
a shop owner did you have you understand
anyway thank you very much you're
welcome
oh man what's he doing
the video that has gone viral and as a
direct result there has been process in
heaven
how you've seen it well how can they
come into a two minute video
that's wrong that's wrong like at least
I'll tell you something yeah even about
six of videos you should not trust our
judgment on Twitter videos
to do it I thought I'd do it you know
and I'm wrong for that you know
sometimes you have to check it you know
what I'll give you an example let me
give you analogy imagine I'll show you a
video of a police officer slapping a
woman
stop him and now your perception now and
your judgment is going to change you
understand so I'm gonna make comments on
the two two minutes video but I'm saying
if this happened and you know it's wrong
you understand can I say I agree with
you I only wish other people were of the
same as yourself don't jump to
conclusions find out the facts
because of social media oh my God
foreign